[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici on le consomme le plus souvent en
cari avec du boucané le babafig plat
apprécié de la cuisine réonnaise et des
dormais préparé d'une manière plus
inattendue en confiture une idée
originale né de l'Esprit fertile et
novateur de Gérard hangama chef
d'entreprise dynamique qui fait briller
le soleil de la Réunion même par-delà
les
océans on est sur une île n Baba fig n
plein de fruits rares longtemps qu'elle
a été utilisé à profusion qui
représentter le Furon de l'agriculture
rignonaise il y a 20 une trentaine
d'années de cela et maintenant tout tout
ça est tombé en aux oubliettes donc pour
moi c'est un peu un crève cœur donc
d'avoir toutes ces richesses comme ça
non utilisé et c'est à partir de cet
instant de on va dire de fiatter de
réignonné que on a pris l'initiative de
dire ben on crée comme ça on fait de
l'innovation avec babafig avec chouchou
avec vavang l'huile essentielle de
géranium de vetver et toutes sortes de
produits que nous transformes ici la
transformation de sa nouvelle création
la confiture de fleurs de bananier aux
huiles essentielles de vétis ver
commence ici avec la préparation des
babafig voilà il faut faire du parage
enlever toutes les braqueté que que nous
voyons ici où c'est
concentré la plupart de la mertume est
concentré en dessous de ces bractet dans
ces fleurs femelles et fleurs malâ qui
est composé de pistilLe d'étamine et
avec à l'intérieur des molécules qui
donnent cette amertume à au
babafig une amertume qu'il convient donc
d'éliminer pour ses préparations en
confiture Gérard rangama prend des
babafic d'une variété de banane idéal
pour cette recette la Gabou cette
variété là nous convient parfaitement
parce que on a un bon rendu et puis
lorsque l'amertume est enlevée il reste
encore un petit côté un peu parfumé au
niveau du du goût de la flotte bananier
c'est ça qui qui pour nous est très
intéressant c'est ce que nous retient
là-dessus parce que notre formation est
basée sur
vraiment l'approche sensorielle
organoloptique du du produit c'est un
produit qu'on vend un peu en épicerie
fine entre guillemets donc on recherche
vraiment le le côté un peu
rare après une première phase de
trempage dans de l'eau salée vinaigrée
les morceaux de babafig sont alors
hachés le plus finement
possible donc là on le broit
doucement la difficulté c'est que dans
dans le baba fig il y a beaucoup de
fibres donc c'est pour ça il est
important de laisser
longtemps voilà de de Boyer très
longuement de façon à ce que toutes les
fibres soi soi cassé à
[Musique]
l'intérieur chef d'entreprise dynamique
gérardam a conjuguer avec avec succès
depuis une vingtaine d'années maintenant
l'aspect économique au volet insertion
sociale les deux maillons fort de sa
société soleil réunion qui explique bien
ce que cela veut dire
euh produit du terroir de la réunion à
fa perspective de développement et que
je souhaite remettre au goût du jour
retravailler toutes les aspects
ingrédients recherche innovation et qui
a une passerelle également avec que
l'employabilité l'insertion des jeunes
toujours à la recherche de l'innovation
dans sa gamme de produits
agroalimentaires Gérard rangama et son
équipe travaillent depuis 6 mois à la
mise au point d'une confiture de babafig
aux huiles essentielles de vétivvert
pays nous notre objectif c'est
justement sur d'aller sur ce terrain où
on est audacieux et avec cette approche
utopique de prendre un produit comme ça
qui n'a plus de valeur euh qui est jeté
pratiquement et de redonner vie de faire
qui a une forte valeur ajoutée lorsque
le produit est transformé ça c'est
vraiment une des des notions fortes une
de nos qualités chez Soleil Réunion
c'est de prendre quelque chose qui n'a
plus de valeur et de le remettre sur un
piédestal de la préparation des babafig
à leur cuisson tout en douceur chaque
étape de la recette est réalisée avec
les plus grands soins jusqu'à la phase
ultime C qui donnera son goût et son
parfum à cette confiture hors du
commun pe dire c'est la phase
essentielle voilà phase essentielle avec
l'huile essentielle de V donc je vais
verser Vincent tu touilles tout de suite
et on ferme pendant quelques minutes
d'accord et puis après on fait une
dégustation et et on empte alors attends
avant de
tourner parce que le problème c'est que
l'uile est très
concentré et ça peut
le il faut que ça soit
vraiment senti à
peine une goutte et demi voilà
allez tourne tourne tourne tourne voilà
une goutte et demi ça doit nous donner
vraiment juste le parfum c'est petite
dose mais avant la mise en peau il faut
encore goûter et évaluer cette nouvelle
confiture c'est très
chaud le parfum de VVER pas trop trop
fort mais juste léger pour donner envie
de de le manger prend pas le dessus qui
ne prend pas le dessus VO prend pas le
dessus c'est moins fort que les tests
qu'on avait fait à l'époque donc je
pense que on on n pas loin de comment
diraisje de de la qualité qu'on qu'on
recherche voilà la texture semble bien
euh le goût
également après effectivement il va
falloir il va falloir expliquer faire
connaître en métropole et à l'extérieur
ben c'est quoi le baba fig c'est pour ça
on appelle ça nous flot bananier faut
nous faire comprendre à
[Musique]
l'extérieur